ecological breakdown exacerbated by
climate change has led to conflict and
created a vicious cycle which might have
gone beyond the point of no return
that's the conclusion of a report out
today from the institute of economics
and peace now the starkest example they
give is afghanistan so is there a way of
breaking this downward spiral and who
bears responsibility and i'm going to
kick off with you and there is one
recent report that found that climate
change has influenced up to 20
of armed conflict over the last century
that's a staggering figure isn't it and
perhaps you could talk us through that
terrible cycle that involves climate
change and conflict
absolutely and i mean climate change is
a kind of a multiplier whereby if you
have um some kind of natural resource
degradation or you have a natural
disaster maybe it's a wildfire maybe
it's a drought maybe it's a flood
perhaps instigated or made more likely
by climate change then you have very
difficult conditions in the immediate
aftermath and the competition and the
kind of um the lack of resources in
those situations can result in conflict
in fact i think there's been some work
that showed that
the conflict in syria was at least in
part um intensified by by drought
conditions and in the years immediately
proceeding but these sorts of um events
can
amplify conflict and then you get this
kind of vicious cycle where conflict is
then exacerbated by climate change and
climate change exacerbates conflict
so stanley fighting over land and
resources is nothing new is it but how
much worse do you think it's going to
get in the years ahead because of
climate change
well i can remember when i joined the
world bank in the 60s the first thing i
did was work on the indus basin and that
had actually been a war and there was a
war between pakistan and india i think
it was 1960 united 61. and the solution
there of course was to improve the water
supply between the two countries and
what they do they did that then by
building the mangler dam and the
tarbella dam and a few whole series of
link canals yes the conflict uh over
resources is absolutely vital as ever
says
climate change has a way of exacerbating
that conflict
in so many ways just a very quick
thought on what we do about it is there
responsibility for for for rich nations
in the west to to help yes
you're absolutely right as we face as we
come up to cop 26 what is the issue on
the table on the resource front um well
of course is whether with whether the
great nations will come up with 100
billion dollars a year they promise and
of course some of that money has
certainly maybe a third even has
certainly to go to what you might call
mitigation adaptation and that of course
means resolving conflicts it's a big
subject we'll have to revisit another
time but we're out of time for now
stanley johnson and ella gilbert really
good sibo thanks very much indeed
you